I'm only quoting it for what it says one
place it says the Disciples of Jesus
were Muslims Abraham was a Muslim Moses
was a Muslim other people before
Muhammad were Muslims then it says
Muhammad was the first Muslim that's
what it says that's that's all okay I
got the hello man how you doing
dangerous lions alhamdulillah how are
you I'm good praise the Lord so I wanted
to came up to come up just to say
something if you allow me to are you
coming up to engage yeah of course all
right yeah go ahead what you got to say
yeah so what I have to say is like why
aren't you holding the same standard
like why do you have a double standard
because when we look at the Bible
there's a ton of
contradictions that you should be
solving for the Christian people instead
of just attacking Islam all day long you
know how do you know how to attack Islam
all day long well that's all you talk
about like go spread your religion and
you know like focus on that you be
watching some sometimes do you uh get
entertained sometimes you can be honest
oh yeah I'm always honest so I don't
really watch a lot I actually like feel
sorry for you that you use this much
time spread spreading Islam instead of
focusing
on do you do you enjoy when you watch I
don't watch you a lot man I'm being
honest how do you know how much how do
you know I spend a lot of time talking
about because time I scroll you have
some you're you're talking about Islam
really like every time it sounds it
sounds like you watch me every time no
man I don't I'm really not a lot on Tik
Tok I open my own lives for the most of
the part that's good but that's all man
like like I have I have a large I have a
large Muslim fan base like it's okay
yeah I get it but like what like how
many like if we do a percentage of how
many Muslims talk about Christianity and
how many Christians talk about Islam I
would like there's a huge difference no
I don't think so I would say it's about
the same actually no it's it's not about
the same we have dawa people yes and
those people spread Islam they don't go
and be like oh this is wrong and this is
this and contradiction here and
contradiction there and like try to put
Christians on the spot all the time yes
yes yes they do they literally have
posters saying with with a fake picture
of Jesus holding a Quran saying
Christians why you uh worship a Muslim
man yeah actually wait wait let me
finish they also have a background
saying uh does God have a son yes or no
Christians answer it's a blue background
I don't know if you probably seen it or
not they also have um another one saying
uh Abraham Moses and Jesus were Muslims
why aren't you uh talking about talking
to Christians you know uh God is not a
trinity um they also have one saying uh
the Trinity is illogical come
I got the point I got the point got the
point what I do actually what I do is I
go into these lives and I tell them the
same thing I'm telling you no you don't
no you don't yeah I do and if they have
an impro like not appropriate picture
about Jesus or anything like that I I
call it out I'm like that's har on don't
do that do all right do me this favor
because I I'm I'm gonna be real with you
I don't believe you but why would I lie
to you like what you think I'm scared of
you like not scared of me but you know
for to sound
no bro I I don't really care I don't
care that much I don't know I don't know
I I just I find that hard to believe not
calling you a liar I just find that hard
to believe but if you do next time you
do it next time matter fact do this for
me the next time you see a Muslim live
and it's and it's and it's directed
towards Christian Christian beliefs
mentions Jesus or anything like that
Trinity Muhammad in the Bible anything
in the Bible I want you to record
yourself going on stage why would prove
myself to you I don't care man I'm just
I'm just telling you this like this is
an honest advice from me to
you me as a Muslim When I See This like
I don't need your advice though I don't
need your advice yeah but like okay
don't take the advice I'm telling you
how I feel me as a Muslim when I see
this I I don't need your advice can I
can I just finish my statement well no
because you're because at this point now
you're just giving me like filibustering
your feelings I I don't I do not care
about that I care about what truth well
you do care about Muslims right of
course yeah so as a Muslim when I see
this this
is this is why my care about Muslims
pushes them to begin to for the first
time in their lives begin to think about
their religion and then also consider
Christ we've had a lot of people change
their minds this year a lot of Muslims
yeah that's cool man that's all cool
that's all cool but like that you have a
double standard this is the core of my
point okay
okay you're looking at oh did Muhammad
say this first or did Abraham say it
first and this is a contradiction but
you have way more clear contradictions
in the Bible that you should like defend
for your followers over here because as
soon as somebody ask that question like
you with all the respect the whole
religion crumbles I got you so so how
does that help you with this
contradiction that I that I mentioned
how does that help you solve it I don't
see it as a contradiction if somebody is
in a village he says I'm the first and
then somebody else says I'm the first
they're both the first that's impossible
no that's not impossible if I'm if
somebody's the first doctor over there
and then somebody else comes and he's
the first doctor of his family it's not
a contradiction at all I I agree if that
qualification is included if it's
specific on you know what they're the
first of then I agree with you it's not
a contradiction unfortunately the the
Quran doesn't qualify the Quran just
says these people were Muslims and these
people are before Muhammad and then it
mentions how Muhammad was the first
Muslim it doesn't say first of his first
Muslim of his Nation first Muslim of his
people first Muslim of his area it just
says Muhammad was the first Muslim well
it doesn't say what you're trying to say
either what what do what do you mean it
means it doesn't say he's the first
Muslim of all mankind and Abraham
doesn't say he's the first Muslim of all
mankind it doesn't it doesn't have to if
if if there's Muslims that existed
before Muhammad and it and it says that
Muhammad was the first Muslim without
qualifying like oh of his area or oh of
his Nation or
oh the point that's the point didn't
qualify so why you
in if it doesn't qualify it my friend if
it doesn't qualify it then it's a
contradiction no not because it didn't
qualify he said mam is listen listen if
he said Muhammad was the first of
mankind and then Abraham said he's the
first of mankind yes that would be a
clear contradiction but it didn't say
that yeah that would be another clear
contradiction but unfortunately yeah
that would be a clear contradiction no
that would be a clear contradiction but
what you're trying to say now is you're
interpreting one way when it's open to
multiple opinions it's not clear
contradiction well this is my thing um
you can have whatever opinion you want
on what the it's not an opinion if
somebody says he's the first let me
finish you can we can apply our own
thoughts and our own opinions to any
text we want to make it say or mean
whatever we want it to say to fit our
narrative we can do that me I'm actually
Sten true to what the Quran says itself
without adding to it I'm only quoting it
for what it says one place it says the
Disciples of Jesus were Muslims Abraham
was a Muslim Moses was a Muslim other
people before Muhammad were Muslims then
it says Muhammad was the first Muslim
that's what it says that's that's all
okay I got the was Muhammad the first
Muslim in Mecca yes or no yes okay so
it's not a contradiction because he was
the first Muslim doeses it say in Mecca
yeah exactly it doesn't say anything
else either so that means that it's are
you like hinting like if there would be
like a real contradiction like it it
should be stronger than this and this is
exactly my point you have such a double
standard this is my point you have such
a double standard because there's way
more clear contradictions like clear
there's no discussion about those
contradictions in the Bible I think
you're showing the double standard now
because it's it sound like you're you're
saying that there's clear contradictions
in the Bible
but when a clear contradiction is
brought up to to you in the Quran you
make excuses for not the same excuses
Liberties Muhammed the first in Mecca
was he the first Muslim in Mecca or no
you said it doesn't say that so that's
irrelevant dude it doesn't say anything
else either but that's what the verse
means it means he was the first Muslim
in his
era thanks thanks for coming man I
appreciate yeah of course you're going
to kick me look at the
in the Bible defend those because those
are clear contradictions that's that's
my message when you're intellectually
dishonest you can't you you're not going
to you know stay on the stage for a long
time I can't I can't I won't deal with
it you know I choose me